this is what the road to human
immortality looks like
to battle aging people receive
customized Fountain of Youth treatments
DNA repair
cellular Rejuvenation or even organ
replacement
the realistic Prospect of healthy
eternal life is fundamentally reshaping
Society
oh this I want to try today scientists
are blazing a trail to this very future
we are at war with death I want to know
what breakthroughs are being made we can
build an organ that matches your body
this cocktail seems to reverse aging
that will Forge the future to so complex
human immortality
[Music]
thank you
my name is Marin hunsberger I'm a
microbiologist and I'm fascinated by how
the future inspires the progress of
Science and Technology but I'm critical
of Sensational science headlines that
promise immortality
still all of these stories have prompted
me to ask how quickly am I aging to find
out I recently took a blood test I
mailed it off and now the results have
just come in I in like real life I'm 26
and we're about to see what this
biological aging test
says I am so my biological age according
to this test is
40. learning my body has aged 14 years
faster than expected is not the result I
was hoping for but it makes sense my
life partner was recently diagnosed with
cancer and I guess that stress has
clearly taken a toll while I have some
doubts about the accuracy of this
particular test I am concerned that
stress could further affect my health in
the future so I want to find out is it
scientifically possible to slow or even
stop the aging process altogether if so
what will our lives be like in the
future
please
we're in Vegas
to find out I'm attending rad Fest where
a group of experts are gathering to put
an end to old age
this event bills itself as the Woodstock
of radical life extension
[Applause]
I'm immediately struck by the extremely
bold claims of healing and even
immortality
[Music]
have to learn how
they're doing really good and life is
great you're going to want to keep on
going so what do you think
Festival director James stroll calls
himself an anti-death activist I want to
live indefinite lifespan that's what I'm
after I want to live forever that's my
goal okay I personally think it's better
to go for it and lose and not try at all
right sure what perceptions about aging
and death in the public are you hoping
to change like what would you want
people to take away yeah most people are
pretty much I'll use the term programmed
that death is inevitable and we want to
change that Paradigm we see aging as a
disease a curable disease and we're at
war with death
the idea that aging might be cured like
a disease is relatively new
but this yearning for Eternal youth goes
back thousands of years
Cleopatra is supposedly bathed in sour
donkey's milk to make her skin appear
more youthful and since then people have
tried using everything from raw meat to
guinea pig testicles and even menstrual
blood to combat the aging process
blood appears to be a recurring theme in
this quest for immortality
some ultra wealthy patients are trying a
controversial new therapy they're
receiving transfusions of blood products
taken from teenagers in the hopes of
rewinding their biological clocks so far
this process has yielded no measurable
benefits
[Music]
there are dozens of therapies available
at the radfest marketplace I'm wondering
are there claims based on sound science
oh this I want to try this procedure
claims to boost a person's energy at the
cellular level
while reducing Stress and Anxiety how
does the red light rejuvenate my
mitochondria a lot of the research looks
at decreasing inflammation improving the
blood flow this treatment is supposed to
boost the immune these machines are
hydrogen inhalation devices and what's
the hydrogen you're supposed to do so
it's basically a master antioxidants and
anti-inflammatory
this device promises to relieve pain
throughout the entire body so this is
the Addison what this does is it infuses
heat throughout your circulatory system
just by delivering heat to my hand yes
and they also have done research in the
diabetes Arena cardiovascular and also
autism
the Spiel that they have contains a lot
of scientific words peppered in there
which are legitimate scientific words
that refer to a real phenomenon but it
plays into this idea that anything that
sounds sciency is true and that you
should believe it and trust it but that
does not mean that their product is
going to make you live longer though I'm
sympathetic to the anti-aging cause for
very personal reasons from a scientific
point of view I don't think the remedies
on display here will lead us down the
path toward immortality in the future
to find a more realistic path I'm at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology to
meet a Pioneer in longevity research Dr
Leonard gorente
he's taking on a big problem that most
everyone will eventually face as you get
older you lose muscle mass and you gain
fat Mass okay and both of those things
are bad sure Lenny is a firm believer in
the power of exercise to keep our bodies
healthier for longer by impacting agent
you can not only improve health but help
mitigate diseases
at his Cutting Edge lab his team
identified the first longevity Gene and
this breakthrough opened the door to the
possibility that we might one day
control the aging process in living
organisms
I think the best case scenario was
attempting really to maintain what we
call Health span
if people live healthier lives for as
long as possible and really compress
morbidity to a very short period at the
end of life
that's my goal instead of slowly
declining in our 60s plagued by things
like heart disease dementia and cancer
Lenny thinks we could live until 90 and
then make a fast and relatively peaceful
decline into death
to make this a reality Lenny is
combating the aging process at the
cellular level so I'd love to walk
through the molecular cellular basis of
aging and what's happening in ourselves
as we age okay yeah let me draw a cell
okay
so there's the cell
mitochondria they produce the energy
this will be the nucleus here okay
chromosomes
in the DNA
DNA contains all of the information for
maintaining cells and building new ones
and those cells are busy dividing
but here's the problem for achieving
immortality cells have a kind of
internal time limit
after about 50 replications they can't
divide anymore
this roadblock is known as the hayflick
limit
for that as a person's cells divide they
also accumulate damage and release toxic
waste byproducts as these toxins build
up over time the affected cells
gradually lose their ability to function
this is the aging process at cellular
levels
that's the important thing about living
Critters is we do have things break down
but we also have the ability to repair
damage sure in principle the goal would
be to boost the ability to repair the
damage to capitalize on this process of
regeneration Lenny and his team targeted
a gene in live round worms called Sir II
there are two genes create proteins
called sirtuins these sirtuins
coordinate the cell's response to stress
including repairing DNA damage which can
slow the aging process
oh my God they're alive oh yeah they're
moving around they look like little
threads so we first looked at the
roundworms and we found that yes the
worms sertugine was involved in aging
and so by extension then we think this
is going to be true universally and
there's tremendous amount of evidence
now that shows that these certains
regulate aging
by inserting extra copies of the
third worm
and increase the lifespan of a worm by
50 percent that's the equivalent of
increasing the global average human
lifespan from 72 to 108. what we know
about sirtuins is that we can intervene
and make people healthy for a decade
longer than they are now Lenny has found
a fascinating connection between these
genes and the body's natural survival
mechanisms and it upturns many of our
assumptions studies of mice and rhesus
monkeys suggest that the production of
certains increases in times of stress
including when food is scarce animals on
a very low calorie diet age more slowly
that's so insane to me that means you
can identify compounds that increase the
activity of certains dynamic What
calorie restriction would normally do
right so you don't actually have to
calories this process gives all the
health benefits of a low-calorie diet
without going hungry
Lenny wants to apply this discovery to
everyone he is now testing a new dietary
supplement to increase the activity of
certains in humans so that's one of
those rare moments where in an instant
you have something that you know is
going to be big that was kind of I
believe was the aha moment that's really
the only time I've ever experienced
something like that
why pushing the
Ledger path toward human immortality
in the future a high-tech procedure
optimizes Health spans the treatment
stimulates longevity genes and mimics
full body calorie restriction this
regular toxin cleanse and cellular
Rejuvenation extends lifelong Health to
averages well past 125.
even if scientists can slow aging like
this how will it actually feel
physically to grow this old over at the
MIT H lab Samantha Brady is exploring
the impact of extended longevity on the
function of the human body we are in
this unprecedented time of longevity
back in the 1900s average lifespan for
people was about late 40s seriously so
that's crazy to think I did not know
that
everyone is living longer lives thanks
to advances like greater access to clean
water antibiotics and vaccines
now we have about a 30-year bonus but
it's not all Rosy Sam helped develop a
suit that well simulates what my body
might feel like at upwards of 70. so
we're gonna start with this weighted
vest this is one of the pieces that's
going to help stimulate what muscle loss
okay okay
we'll just strap you in this suit mimics
the shortening of our ligaments oh my
God they're heavy spinal compression and
the loss of balance that occurs as the
years go by let's pop the goggles on it
also simulates loss of vision and
hearing you are now Agnes transformation
complete I definitely feel like a
different person
I always imagine myself enjoying my life
as I get older give it a shot that's
about as far as I can go but it's pretty
hard to do anything in this suit oh
yeah that's rough
I can get my knees a couple of inches
off the floor and that's it
now I'm worried that as I age I won't be
able to do the things I love anymore so
it looks like this is pretty tiring
already with just a couple of photos
and I keep thinking about the results
from my biological aging tests which
mean this could be a reality for me
sooner than expected it's actually
pretty terrifying
can't wait till I can take it off and
then imagining like
there are some people who can't take it
off this is clearly not how people want
to feel when they are 100 150 or ever
the decline of muscles and the skeletal
system is just the tip of the iceberg
as cells stop dividing they accumulate
damage which ultimately can cause tissue
and organs to fail in the heart this
means valves and the muscle itself can
become thicker and stiffen reducing
blood flow
incredibly heart disease is actually the
number one cause of death around the
world
and to combat organ failure like this
scientists are working around the clock
to find unique Solutions
[Music]
I'm in Houston Texas to meet a scientist
who could revolutionize the way we
Source organs for transplants she's
often been called the doctor
Frankenstein of this area and so I am
bringing her a little gift
Dr Doris Taylor is growing hearts in the
lab
and she's closer than ever to making
lab-grown organ transplants for humans a
reality
[Music]
I have a gift for I don't normally get a
heart as hard as a gift how cool is that
we call these our Ghost Car ghost Hearts
it's amazing to see the engineered
organs up close this is a rabbit heart
and it's about the size of a pediatric
newborn human heart wow
Doris can you tell me how you got in to
a field like this I wanted to make a
difference in the world my twin brother
was sick his entire life and then when I
was six my dad died
it motivates me when I think about that
feeling of helplessness to want to make
a difference in the lives of people with
disease
because people are living longer with
heart disease many people develop heart
failure the only definitive cure for
heart failure is a heart transplant
every 10 minutes a new person goes on
the organ transplant waiting list so
clearly people don't get the organs they
need we can change that we can build an
organ that matches your body and you can
live longer and live healthier
the first step Doris takes in building a
new heart is to strip the tissue and
cells from an animal heart using a wash
of detergents what remains is
effectively the protein scaffolding of a
heart if you look at this this is the
pig heart that we've washed all the
blood out of it's so complex so it's
beautiful it is it's beautiful it's
humbling you're holding an organ
the next step is to grow a new human
heart on top of this animal's
scaffolding
Doris does this by re-cellularizing the
organ with human stem cells
stem cells are cells that are found in
every organ or tissue we all have stem
cells they're cells that respond to
their environment and become like the
cells that surround them certain types
of stem cells can transform into any
kind of cell from blood to liver to
Heart key to the process these stem
cells replicate much more than regular
cells this allows them to grow and cover
the heart scaffolding very quickly this
is one of the rabbit hearts that we've
put cells in
oh my gosh it's in there you can see
that we're getting electrical activity
here from this is like a like an EKG
yeah in there
the EKG machine or electrocardiogram
measures the electrical activity of a
beating heart so one thing is clear it's
alive
I can't see it moving
[Music]
Doris believes that her technique for
building implantable Hearts could be
used to grow other organs as well
but I truly believe if we can go to Mars
we're going to Mars in the lab
we got the rocket ship the scaffold yeah
we've put the astronauts on board the
South yep and now we just got to prove
it's safe you guys are getting there
yeah
and within a decade she thinks she'll be
able to surgically implant lab-grown
organs like these for people in need I
find this hugely moving
I had a patient say you're not building
organs You're Building Hope
this is a path to the future I think we
can all hope for
body part Farms exist in most hospitals
on Earth
organs and limbs can be 3D printed to
order but for emergencies pre-fabricated
organs are available in all blood types
and body sizes with the assistance of
robotic surgeons body parts can be
replaced in under eight minutes
accidents and injuries are no longer
fatal
[Music]
in my quest to unravel The Mystery of
the aging process I'm finding that like
me many scientists are doing this for
personal reasons
earlier this year my partner was
diagnosed with burkett's lymphoma
and it's the fastest growing human
cancer
we just had to think
so much more about the end of our lives
in a way that um you don't have to
usually until
you're well into the
later part of your life
you can find a pathway that will lead us
toward longer and healthier lives
researchers are going deep into the
jungle and to the bottom of the ocean
there scientists have found that Beau
had whales and Greenland sharks can live
well over 200 years while killer whales
live no more than 50.
what makes some creatures live longer
than others
to find out I'm at an aquarium in Las
Vegas to talk with the legendary
gerontologist Aubry dugre about another
long-lived sea creature
the lobster
the big thing that's special about
Lobster is that they live a really long
time there are now reports of lobsters
having lived longer than any human has
lived which is 122 years
incredibly this crustacean doesn't age
at least not in the way human
other thing that locals have the really
big thing they have if they grow and
grow and grow as long as they live
unlike humans a lobster's cells never
stop dividing so this creature never
stops growing they may die due to
predation or disease but not not old age
why does the lobster live so long the
answer can be found in something called
telomeres humans also have telomeres
telomeres are repeating sequences of DNA
at the ends of chromosomes if
chromosomes were shoelaces then
telomeres would be the little protective
caps at the tips these caps protect DNA
during cell division
but as our cells divide throughout our
lifetime these telomeres gradually
shorten
when the telomeres become Too Short The
Cell stops dividing and eventually dies
however there is an enzyme called
telomerase that helps maintain these
protective caps
incredibly Lobster telomeres do not
appear to get shorter over time many
believe this protective enzyme is the
secret to their long lifespan
scientists are currently devising
telomerase treatments to try and produce
the same life-extending effect in humans
what do you think a child born today how
long could they possibly live so really
there is no limit to how long someone
can live
Aubry tells me that a child born today
could benefit from constant scientific
breakthroughs a treatment at 80 years
old might allow them to live to 130 and
future treatments could allow them to
extend their lives potentially for
forever that means that the only limit
to longevity is causes of deaths that do
not have to do with how long ago one
before you know being hit by trucks
bolstering telomeres isn't the only way
to extend human life at the cellular
level
his lab in California Aubry is advancing
the science of anti-aging in another
area
he believes that a lot of the problems
associated with aging happen when cells
become what's called senescent they
don't divide anymore but they don't go
away either some people call them zombie
cells you know essentially Undead the
secreting nasty chemicals that are toxic
to their neighbors and so on but they're
not die so one of the most key
developments in your opinion you think
is in essence getting cells to be better
at taking their own trash out oh yeah
using gene therapies Aubry believes
removing these zombie-like senescent
cells will radically extend our lives it
turns out that we were able to exploit
some really great technology that was
developed for a completely different
reason the technology of what's called
bioremediation which is used in
environmental decontamination so clean
up pollutants that's right they eat up
the oil or the chemical or whatever it
may be so we do the same thing we
identify bacteria that are able to break
down the thing that we're interested in
we identify the genes that they have
that allow them to have this capacity
and we put those dreams into our own
cell
by inserting these new bacterial genes
our bodies might be able to eliminate
these zombie senescent cells most people
didn't take me seriously at all at first
interesting but now this is a totally
mainstream idea while some remain
skeptical of aubry's approach a handful
of Biotech companies are also taking aim
at senescence cells I've never thought
of aging and death as anything but
inevitable so to think of that not
happening I think really upends my world
view
[Music]
in the future a revolutionary new
treatment to destroy zombie cells is
extending human life across the planet
while resting in an oxygen-filled
chamber individuals are injected with
thousands of miniature robots smaller
than red blood cells this Army of
Nanobots scour the body to hunt down and
Destroy every last toxic senescent cell
one treatment every year starting at age
20 extends most human lives by 50
percent
foreign
living to 200 years of age or more may
seem like science fiction and the Big
Challenge in making it science fact lies
in getting these practices to work not
just in lab animals but in humans
in Indiana one Community has already
made steps toward hacking the Aging code
without even knowing it Dr Doug Vaughn
of Northwestern University has
identified a unique and isolated group
of people many of whom are living
dramatically longer than average lives
and it's not who you might expect
there is a large old order Amish
community here that that settled this
region in the early 1800s from
Switzerland from Switzerland yeah
they're living a lifestyle that's very
very homogeneous
the Amish avoid modern technology and
farm using the same traditional tools as
their ancestors
we brought 200 members of the community
into this Center and over two days
extensively studied them did all kinds
of things to measure their biological
age as opposed to their chronological
age cook blood samples measured their
blood pressure measured their telomere
length for Doug the results are
astonishing at multiple levels it looks
like some are protected from aging their
telomeres are longer about 10 percent
longer
they also have a more juvenile
cardiovascular system they're completely
protected from diabetes which is rather
remarkable that might have been the most
striking finding in our studies because
the insulin is thought to be a driver of
aging and aging like pathologies what is
their secret to a long life is it family
history the Amish lifestyle
one member of the Amish community
Neville has agreed to talk to me but for
cultural reasons he's asked that we
don't show his face
so it seems peaceful too and restful
yeah it does get stressful some days
trust me
this is my horse her name is B
B and she's our source of transportation
his family's lifespans are especially
impressive when measured up to the
average global lifespan which is 72. I
understand you had some long-lived
family members back in your family one
was my great grandfather and he lived to
be 92 years old wow and my grandmother
lived to be 86. wow
my great-grandfather had some brothers
that lived to be over a hundred wow wow
yeah
can only one
we like to keep it simple try to be as
self-sufficient as possible try to raise
our own food from the garden or just
people like you are
um you know so I kind of think that it
just depends on what cards get dealt to
your hand
and it turns out Neville is Right some
in this community have won the genetic
Lottery
Doug's research is revealing what that
is
good afternoon I'm Dr Vaughn the first
Clues to the Amish community's longevity
recently surfaced when a member with a
particular blood disorder visited a
modern Clinic do you have any family
members that have that bleeding problem
as present in some of the community
around here my
daughter is the result of a genetic
variation that isn't found anywhere else
in the world
the original founder of the mutation
married into the community in the early
1800s wow he had 15 children and 148
grandchildren in the mid-1800s do the
math
the genetic variation in this Amish
community occurs in a particular Gene
that creates a protein called Pi one
among other things the pi 1 protein
controls the body's senescent or zombie
cells
Doug's research reveals that those in
the community with a single copy of the
gene mutation produce more Pi one
proteins than those with the bleeding
disorder but less than the general
population
and they live dramatically longer lives
why it turns out it's all about balance
Taiwan contributes to a variety of
different disease processes it's not
good to have a lot of pylon it's not
good to have no Pi one it's good to be
in the Goldilocks zone and I have
somewhere in the middle
he wants to hack
the application that essentially mimics
this mutation and regulates the pi one
protein I have a collaborator now in
Japan and after screening a library of
over 3 million compounds they came up
with a group of chemicals that looked
like they might be candidates as Pi one
inhibitors
we've used it in a variety of
experimental studies around the world
has some remarkable effects in terms of
insulin resistance even impacting on the
development of arterial sclerosis or
vascular stiffening if you will
I came into this whole Adventure being
pretty skeptical about a lot of it but I
think digging deeper into the biology
has made me feel that we're at the
beginnings of something really big here
it's a lucky finding I'd never have
imagined that a self-isolated
community's genetic variation would
upend the way scientists think about
everyone's lifespan
blazing a trail to immortality seems
more plausible than I ever imagined
Patrol fertile
fertilizer to slow the aging process
before birth first parents choose from a
menu of longevity genes including the
Amish variant
technicians then customize and engineer
the egg's DNA before fertilization
through this medically regulated
conception newborns can expect to live
200 healthy years or more
while this kind of future seems
appealing what might a healthy
multi-centenarian actually look like to
get a clearer picture of this future I'm
in Los Angeles to meet Lillian Solomon
she just celebrated her 100th birthday
and by all accounts she is the living
embodiment of what all these scientists
aim to achieve she is healthy active and
alert she is a bowling champion and even
has a new boyfriend
I brought you a little cake for us to
all share oh look at that this is my
boyfriend daddy she's an 11 months older
than I am nice I like older women
I have arthritis and I have all the
aches and pains the elderly people get
but somehow it just doesn't seem as bad
I try not to let it deter me from doing
what I want to do as a matter of fact
I'd like to take you to the park and
perhaps show you how I exercise oh yes
please I need some tips
more people are living to over 100 than
ever before while genetics and diet are
important some recent studies show other
key aspects are at play as well on the
road again
what's the secret to staying young for
your whole life I think really number
one is attitude
I think if you have a good attitude and
you would think that today is going to
be better than yesterday
uh that helps
Recent research backs up Lillian's
Theory scientists are finding that many
centenarians have a positive outlook
they are close to their family and are
extroverted
and to this list one study even adds
this trait being stubborn
shall we okay
what do we got in here well I'll do this
nice keep your arms strong
Julian you're so great what a badass if
you don't mind me say some of these I
complained at first I can't do those
exercises just I don't have time if you
want to do them you will make time but
it's good advice it was good advice
Lillian you've inspired me I was just
Blown Away by Lillian in total
especially in her convertible
seeing Lillian with her boyfriend also
made me think about my own relationship
with my partner we recently had the
hopeful news that his cancer is in
remission this turn of events makes me
so thankful for the medical advances of
today but still I want our lives to
continue to be happy and healthy for as
long as possible
it makes me wonder is there actually a
way to stop growing old
it turns out there's one scientist who's
working to truly understand the
biological clock and actually reverse
the aging process thank you so much for
meeting with me here at the fountain of
youth Dr Steve Horvath of UCLA is a
biostatistician who's invented an
intriguing tool that could help us find
a way to roll back the biological clock
Steve created a blood test to determine
biological age
it's widely considered to be the most
accurate in the world
so Dr Horvath why is it important to
have a test like that imagine we want to
prove that this is the Fountain of Youth
right somebody would have to dive into
here we do a before and after
measurement I don't know we would want
to convince ourselves that it actually
rejuvenated the epigenetic age of that
person so it's really useful to have
this clock As the metric to use if
you're thinking of a treatment it's
essential it test for biological aging
is really quintessential in order to
distinguish snake oil from therapies
that actually have an effect Dr
horvath's blood test measures something
called DNA methylation methylation is a
process that regulates how genes
function methyl groups get added to DNA
as we age kind of like rust on metal
using his test Steve has worked out the
average rate that this methylation
happens throughout people's lives
by looking at this methylation change at
a several hundred locations on our DNA
we can very accurately measure the age
of the tissue
some people inherit good genes and their
epigenetic clock simply ticks more
slowly
example are centenarians we analyze
blood samples from centenarians and
their own children and sure enough it
was younger than expected they got lucky
Dr Horvath collaborated with a team to
see if they can replicate this effect
with a drug therapy
over the course of 12 months nine men
took a diabetes drug known as metformin
along with two other kinds of hormones
Steve tested the men's biological age
both before and after the trial and
received some surprising results
when I first ran the statistical
analysis on my computer I was really
blown away I couldn't believe my eyes
this cocktail even seems to reverse
aging
by roughly two and a half years
in effect this mix of medications
reverses that rusting of people's DNA
leading to Visible Changes in the body
there was one gentleman whose hair was
entirely Gray
and after the treatment it was darker
again there was repigmentation if we are
really lucky maybe this treatment this
cocktail really has a holistic effect
that affects many organs of your body
but first this treatment has to be
carefully evaluated and replicated well
makes me trust you
although this study was very small the
promise of reversing the course of Aging
cannot be underestimated it's my dream
that people get an annual measurement of
their methylation and then the doctor
would say you know what you age a little
bit too fast why don't you take this
anti-aging treatment and do you think
that could extend people's lifetimes to
healthy hundred years I am quite
convinced that people live till 150 the
question is only when
Dr horvath's approach added to the mix I
can more clear
path toward
s ended life
each reducing DNA cleanse comes in a
simple pill taken yearly by people over
50. this therapy scrubs the methylation
rust and rejuvenates the whole body at
the cellular level most people's genetic
codes can now be reformulated to the
97th percentile of Optimal Health
whether 50 150 or 200 years old it's
possible to feel like you have the body
of someone in their 30s
as a scientist I'm excited about these
breakthroughs and the future that
science is promising us but as a human
being there are questions outside the
laboratory that seem equally important
to me
it seems that on many levels our limited
lifespan has to find who we are as
humans and I wonder how weed change if
we all live until 150 or even longer
just because we can extend our lifespan
should we
and who will benefit from these
treatments will only the privileged
benefit from this extended life
when it comes to life expectancy in the
future it makes me wonder how class race
and geography might play an even greater
role than they already do
and how will the planet cope with human
immortality
we're already struggling with
overpopulation and resource depletion
but I do feel hopeful that science
technology and pure human Ingenuity can
find solutions to these admittedly
enormous problems
I think my 2050 we'll probably have
human beings that regularly make it to
120. I'm almost certain we're going to
have individuals that live to ages that
we've never seen before
I want to make sure that no parent or no
child has to lose someone they love
they are always unexpected developments
that nobody has foreseen
so they're these breakthroughs suddenly
and if we get lucky we will be able to
reverse the ages of people
while developments in science are
it's clear that there are things we can
all be doing today that may help slow
the aging process like exercising
following a balanced diet and even
simply just keeping a positive outlook
I'm heading back to the lab too where as
a microbiologist I hope in some small
way I can also contribute to all of us
leading happier and healthier lives oh
man if I could live like Lillian I would
live to a hundred if I could live like
Lillian
220 I would live to 120.
so what's going to happen to our world
as a whole as we all live longer lives
but I'm pretty excited to find out
[Music]
thank you foreign